from Moscow to Capitol Hill now
president zielinski from Ukraine
addressing the U.S Congress
[Applause]
good morning Mr President good morning
Madam Ambassador who is with us this
morning Madam ambassador
ambassador matarova
[Applause]
Mr President it is my honor to present
to you the Congress of the United States
which has great respect and admiration
and appreciation for your courageous
leadership members of Congress I have
the high privilege and distinct honor of
presenting to you the president of
Ukraine Vladimir zielinski Slava ukrana
thank you
great to hear us
my colleagues Slava ukrana
[Applause]
glory to Heroes
thank you very much
Madam speaker members of the Congress
ladies and gentlemen
Americans friends
I'm proud to greet you from Ukraine from
our capital city of cave a city that is
under missile and air strikes from
Russian troops every day but it doesn't
give up
and we have not even thought about it
for a second just like many other cities
and communities in our beautiful country
which found themselves in the worst war
since World War II
I have the honor to greet you on behalf
of the Ukrainian people Brave and
freedom loving people who for eight
years have been resisting the Russian
aggression
those who give their best
Sons and Daughters to stop this
full-scale Russian invasion
right now the destiny of our country
is being decided
the destiny of our people whether
ukrainians will be free whether they
will be able to preserve their democracy
Russia has attacked not just us not just
our land not just our cities it went on
a brutal offensive against our values
basic human values it through tanks and
planes against our freedom against our
right to live freely in our own country
or future
foreign
for happiness against our national
dreams just like the same dreams you
have you Americans
just
like anyone else in the United States I
remember your National Memorial in
Rushmore
the faces of your prominent presidents
those who laid the foundation of the
United States of America as it is today
democracy Independence freedom and care
for everyone for every person for
everyone who works diligently who lives
honestly who respects the law we in
Ukraine want the same for our people
all that is normal part of your own life
ladies and gentlemen
friends Americans in your great history
you have pages that would allow you to
understand ukrainians understand us now
when you need it right now when we need
you right now remember Pearl Harbor
terrible morning of December 7 1941 when
your sky was black from the planes
attacking you just remember it remember
September the 11th a terrible day in 20
2001 when evil tried to turn your cities
independent territories
in battlefields when innocent people
were attacked
attacked from Air yes
just like nobody else expected it you
could not stop it our country
experienced the same every day right now
at this moment every night for three
weeks now various Ukrainian cities
Odessa and Hercules
Russia has turned the Ukrainian Sky into
a source of death for thousands of
people
Russian troops have already fired nearly
1 000 missiles at Ukraine countless
bombs they use drones to kill us with
Precision this is a terror that Europe
has not seen has not seen for 80 years
and we are asking for a reply for an
answer to this Terror from the whole
world is this a lot to ask for to create
a no-fly zone Zone over Ukraine to save
people is this too much to ask
humanitarian no-fly zone
something that Ukraine that Russia would
not be able to terrorize our free cities
if this is too much to ask we offer an
alternative you know what kind of
Defense systems we need as 300 and other
similar systems you know how much
depends on the battlefield on the
ability to use aircraft powerful strong
Air Aviation to protect our people our
freedom Our Land
aircraft that can help Ukraine
help Europe
and you know that they exist and you
have them but they are on Earth not in
Ukraine in the Ukrainian Sky they do not
defend our people I have a dream these
words are known to each of you today I
can say I have a need
I need to protect our Sky I need your
decision your health which means exactly
the same the same you feel when you hear
the words I have a dream
ladies and gentlemen
friends
Ukraine is grateful to the United States
for its overwhelming support for
everything that U.S government and your
people have done for us for weapons and
ammunition for training for finances for
leadership in the Free World which helps
us to pressure the aggressor
economically I am grateful to President
Biden for his personal involvement for
his sincere commitment to the defense of
Ukraine and democracy all over the world
I am grateful to you for the resolution
which recognizes All Those who commit
crimes against Ukraine against the
Ukrainian people as war criminals
however now it is true in the darkest
time for our country for the whole
Europe I call on you to do more new
packages of sanctions are needed
constantly every week until the Russian
military machine stops
restrictions are needed for everyone on
whom there's unjust regime is based we
propose that the United States sanctions
all politicians in the Russian
Federation who remain in their offices
and do not uh cut ties with those who
are responsible for the aggression
against Ukraine from State Dumas members
to the last official who has lack of
morale to break the state Terror all
Americans company must leave Russia from
their Market leave their Market
immediately because it is flooded with
our blood ladies and gentlemen members
of Congress please take the lead if you
have companies in your districts who
finance the Russian military machine
leaving business in Russia you should
put pressure I'm asking to make sure
that the Russians do not receive a
single penny that they use to destroy
people in Ukraine
the destruction of our country the
destruction of Europe All American ports
should be closed for uh Russian Goods we
um the peace is more important than
income and we have to defend this
principle in the whole world we already
became part of the anti-war Coalition a
big anti-war Coalition that unites many
countries dozens of countries those who
reacted to in principle to President
Putin's decision to invade our country
but we need to move on and do more we
need to create new tools to respond
quickly and stop the war the full-scale
Russian invasion of Ukraine which began
on February 24th and it would be fair if
it ended in a day in 24 hours that evil
would be punished immediately
today
the world does not have
such tools the war of the past have
prompted our predecessors to create
institutions that should protect us from
war but they unfortunately don't work we
see it you see it so we need new ones
new institutions new alliances and we
offer them we propose to create an
association
U24 United for peace a union of
responsible countries that have the
strength and Consciousness to stop
conflicts immediately provide all the
necessary assistance in 24 hours if
necessary even weapons if necessary
sanctions humanitarian support political
support finances everything you need to
keep the peace and quickly
save the world to save lives in addition
such associations such unions could
provide assistance to those who are
experienced natural disasters man-made
disasters who felt victims to
humanitarian crisis or epidemics
remember how difficult it was for the
world to do the simplest thing just to
give vaccines vaccines against covet to
save lives to prevent new strains the
world spent months years doing things
like that much faster to make sure there
are no human losses no victims ladies
and gentlemen
Americans if such Alliance would exist
today that is U24 we would be able to
save thousands of lives in our country
in many countries of the world those who
need peace
those who suffer inhumane destruction I
ask you to watch one video video of what
the Russian troops did in our country in
our land we have to stop it we must
prevent it preventively destroy every
single aggressor who seeks to subjugate
other nations please watch the video
foreign
[Music]
so if you're just joining us this is
Capitol Hill
Congress being addressed by the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
on a video link
uh he's now showing them a video I guess
juxtaposing
uh the Kiev and the Ukraine that he
knows almost looked like a sort of
tourist video at the start with the
reality of what it is now whilst that is
playing I will just tell you about some
of what
president zielinski has said
he actually started by invoking for an
American audience
past events things like Pearl Harbor and
911 telling the Americans to remember
those moments remember what those were
like for you how distressing how
life-changing they were and in response
to that he said we need you right now
president zielinski then also talking
about
as he has consistently asked for a
no-fly zone he said is this too much to
ask for
and if it is too much to ask for well
we've got an alternative we need defense
systems we need powerful aircrafts to
protect our people
the same sort of things we have heard
from him
no-fly zone to defend the skies is what
he asked for but we know that the US and
NATO have consistently said that would
not
happen president zielinski calling on
all U.S businesses to leave Russia and
to make sure and his words that Russian
uh Russians got no money not a single
penny I think is what he said
uh to keep inflicting the war as they
are
we'll just apologize as well obviously
these pictures coming in unedited and
there are some distressing images there
uh the reality of what is happening in
Ukraine at the moment looks like that's
finished let's go back to president
zielinski and
in the end to sum it up
today
today it's not enough to be the leader
of the niche
today it takes to be the leader of the
world being the leader of the world
means to be the leader of peace
peace in your country doesn't depend
anymore only on you and your people
it depends on those next to you
and those who are strong
doesn't mean big
strong is brave and ready to fight for
the life of his citizens and citizens of
the world
for human rights for freedom for the
right to live distantly and to die when
your time comes
and not when it's wanted by someone else
by your neighbor
today the Ukrainian people are defending
not only Ukraine we are fighting for the
values of Europe and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the American people are
helping not just Ukraine
but Europe and the world to keep the
planet alive
to keep Justice in history
now I am almost 45 years old today my
age stopped when the heart of more than
100 children
of beating I see no sense in life
if it cannot stop the death
and this is my main issue at the leader
of my people
great ukrainians
and at the leader of my Niche I am
addressing the President Biden
you are the leader
of the niche
of your verification
I wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means to
be the leader of peace
thank you travel crane
glory to Ukraine
[Applause]
that's the end of proceedings from the
US Congress they're
Vladimir zielinski ending his address in
English notably most of his address is
given in Ukrainian but he spoke in
English and a direct plea to President
Biden right at the end you are the
leader of your great nation I wish you
to be the leader of the world to be the
leader of peace
she had pretendsi is our correspondent
on Capitol Hill
uh on this Wednesday shehab good morning
to you let's go through some of that I
mean it was the US Congress is a
famously divided place at the best of
times but total Unity shown there for
president zelensky
right but as you suggested in your
earlier summation while that video was
playing a slickly produced video
as is often the case when zelenski
addresses A legislature you can tell
that this is also not just addressing
the members of parliament or congress in
this case who are gathered there no not
least nor even President Biden in this
case but also to the people of America
as a whole it's clearly captured the
imagination of many here in in the U.S
so when zelenski asks is it too much to
ask for a no-fly zone and if and if it
is too much then can we get a Surface to
our missile system the S400 is being
discussed this is also to increase that
Grassroots pressure on members of
Congress and and President Biden the
fact is though as you mentioned as far
as a majority in Congress and President
by the concern the no-fly zone is too
much because that could lead to an
all-out war with Russia it could lead to
a shooting war with Russia which could
lead to nuclear conflagration flag
ration you know mutually assured Mutual
discussion and it's interesting when
we're thinking about public opinion in
the context of this speech there was a
very interesting poll this week from CBS
when members of when those being asked
were asked Point Blank do you do you
believe in a no-fly zone to help Ukraine
a majority 59 said yes
41 said no but when it was explained to
Americans that a no-fly zone would be
seen as an act of War by Russia that
reverses and it becomes 38 in favor and
62 percent in opposition so again
zelinski not explaining the the
complexities of a no-fly zone this isn't
just a matter of of planes flying and
protecting humanitarian corridors this
is actively bombarding potentially
Russian service to our missile systems
and potentially shooting down Russian
Jets which could mean all-out war and as
jansaki said the White House Press
Secretary the day before it is as far as
Joe Biden is concerned he has to look at
the whole picture and it's not in the
National Security interest of the U.S to
have World War III with with Russia
having said that though it's clear that
Biden was expecting as emotionally
charged speech as we did see so we are
going to see Joe Biden speak in a couple
of hours now to itemize the latest
tranche of 800 million dollars is going
to announce off weapons Aid that will be
going to Ukraine and so they will be
trying to get ahead of them this message
and look we are helping but we don't
want world war three no of course can
you give us a little more detail then
she had on not just what is to come but
what the US has already provided because
that's obviously what they will point to
when they say sorry no no-fly zone but
this is what you have got
right why it's interesting because the
White House I will have already itemized
actually they went into great detail in
the last day as to what they've already
given uh so you know 600 Stinger
anti-aircraft missiles 2 600 Javelin
anti-tankner cells five helicopters
three Patrol boats 70 other vehicles 200
grenade launchers it goes on shotguns
machine guns 14 million rounds of
ammunition uh body armor helmets they've
been going into a great pain to say look
this is what we have given and in fact
what the what what the Biden
Administration has been saying is we
don't think and because another another
request from zelensky has been give us
Jets Fighters and the and the my
demonstration keeps saying that we don't
think that's what they need they already
have a sufficient inventory of that they
probably don't have enough Pilots anyway
a lot of these attacks are coming from
Russian airspace anyway but whereas
surface-to-air missiles or other or
rather Stinger missiles that's anti
anti-aircraft anti-tag missiles are
working and as I said though
that's that very public bit of bartering
we heard from zeldenski might be
something that we do hear more about
today where there were some reports so
this is something that the US has been
actually considering which is to give or
trying to get to Ukraine s 300
surface-to-air missiles which could
attack attack Russian planes so that
would be through a third country these
are these are Soviet era or Russian era
russian-made service or air missiles
which ukrainians have already been
trained with so there would be there
would be some sort of facilitation to
get those at the hounds of Ukraine but
all the time the US is weighing a very
particular calculus based both on
international law and on intelligence so
that is at what point do we become a
direct participant in this conflict and
therefore become a direct Target of
Russia and potentially lead to the
conflagration which everyone wants to
avoid and so that's based based on
international law as to what what
constitutes actively intervening in the
war but also on intelligence as to what
Vladimir Putin will feel is the red line
that NATO mustn't cross and up until
this point that has been jet fighters as
far as the U.S is concerned at least
facilitated by by the U.S and service
Red missiles but we're getting some
sense of maybe service aware missiles
that that calculus might be changing but
we'll hear more about that in the coming
hours I think okay sherbertans is on
Capitol Hill as things wrap up there
after that address from Vladimir
zielinski the Ukrainian president